feeding the world is going to be very
difficult moving forward
population goes up we're going to hit 10
billion people in 2050 this is in
your and probably my lifetime
uh and i don't want to see my kids and
my grandchildren that are not born yet
uh involved in the wars over food i
don't think that's where the world wants
to go
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillary stanford leap
and birthright excel
hello and welcome to another episode of
20 minute leaders and we're going to be
talking about agriculture and really the
future of our planet
meet ganesh vered the ceo of smart aggro
r d partnership
an experienced investor in agrotech in
futa companies until recently she was a
venture partner at untreat capital
responsible for agritech and food tech
investments she invested in four
agritech startups and is an active
chairwoman of the board at v aqua and
board members and additional startups
the guinea brings over 20 years of
senior management experience as intel
israel cs site manager and vice
president r d with perigo and hazera
the ganete verde welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you i'm very well how
are you
i'm great thank you so much for joining
me
i'm not going to begin to go with your
list with your incredible background and
right now you're the ceo of smart aggro
fund
and
your work you know over the last few
decades understanding agriculture tech
understanding leadership in the tech
ecosystem and today channeling that
understanding into your thoughts on
what's happening
with with agriculture today and where
we're headed with food scarcity i think
is fascinating so tell me a little bit
about your background and what what
helped you get into agritech
uh it was actually um
a journey not all of the stages of the
journey were precisely planned
uh most of my career i did with intel
corporation i'm a chemical engineering
profession so
uh in the factories of intel
from engineering to r d and later on the
israeli site manager for corporate
services
after 17 years with the intel i decided
to move to
another position and i was the vp rnd of
the carigo the api division
and that was my first you know
full-blown r d
introduction
after that i was the vp rnd of jose and
this was really the place where i got
introduced into agriculture i spent a
lot of time in the fields with the
farmers to make sure that the r d team
developed solutions that meets what the
customer needs
and i realized that the problems go way
beyond just the seeds it goes into
additional issues they need to take care
of
and i made a decision a strategic
decision to move into the
startups innovation arena
with that move i i joined the via aqua
it's a biotechnology company a trendline
company and um i was the chairperson of
the board i was an active chairperson so
i really joined the team and worked with
them
and um
the second thing that i did was being a
ceo of a startup i said i need if i'm my
end in mind is to invest in startups i
need to understand their day-to-day life
and i was able to expl to experience
anything from
the
investor decided not to invest all the
money that he committed to
to uh problems with the
go to market and changing the strategy
and everything
that can go wrong went wrong
um
and uh
almost three years ago i joined the
andre capitan
to
run the investments on agritech
and there i really learned from the best
you know anti-capital and you can see uh
kazoo and monday all the exits
that are happening recently actually
and so i learned from avi yeah
how to invest
and uh what to look for and how to
manage the relationship with the
entrepreneurs and what's important for
the investor and what's important for
the startup and how do you make sure
they're focused so
really excellent experience and four
months ago i decided to move from
a venture partner to a ceo of a starter
of a
investment body which is smart ago and
as i'm very passionate about the
agritech knowing the challenges the
world is
is facing and the big problems we are
heading towards i decided that this is
the right place for me to invest
incredible in agri-tech and future
so
with that it's a perfect segue tell me a
little bit about you know agriculture
tech
what you know what is it about and and
then i'd love to understand a little bit
about you know why why is it important
in your eyes today that we focus on this
i think that everyone knows why it's
important you see the climate change you
see the effects of the climate change
from severe drought that impact for
example the sugarcane
industry in brazil and the grain
of and soy soybeans in in the us it
causes an increase in pricing but not
just that the yields are going down
you see a dramatic impact of the
chemistry that is being used and not all
of chemistry is bad but
a lot of of it influenced badly the
environment
i think the climate change
is something that we're we're seeing now
it's gonna get worse if we don't do
something very drastic in the next
few years we're not talking about
let's take care of it in 50 years this
is like the money time right now
and i think that the aspects of
agritech finding solutions for
a for example for a degradation of the
soil
ability of the plant to deal with
weather conditions the ability to change
the way we approach agriculture putting
technology into agriculture
and trying through the genetics to solve
the problems all of those things are
bundled together and require dramatic
solutions so
you can see solutions from
you know um the side of manpower people
don't really want to work in agriculture
who wants to work 50 degrees celsius in
the sun and
get the onions out of the soil not fun
and
second thing that you see is dramatic
reduction in the number of bees
now i think about 70 of what we see
fruits and vegetables in the in the
supermarket are being pollinated by bees
so that's a dramatic thing that is
happening as well
so
trying to find solutions for all those
uh
those
items is critical for the survival of
the planet i'm saying feeding the world
is going to be very difficult moving
forward population goes up we're going
to hit 10 billion people in 2050 this is
in
your and probably my lifetime
uh and uh i don't want to see my kids
and my grandchildren that are not born
yet uh involved in the wars over food i
don't think that's where the world want
to go
a hundred percent 100 now
so so we're touching a little bit on the
urgency here because obviously you
mentioned we're all aware
of what's happening in the world in
climate change and everything but but
there is a larger sense of urgency
especially i think you know if i'm
looking at this last decade and sort of
the the evolution of artificial
intelligence you know as a democratized
tool to be building a lot of these tools
that you're
talking about
that are going to enable us to to to
make a lot of these a lot of these
changes can you give me some specific
examples of how technology is being used
with agriculture today in in ways that
are non-trivial i'm the reason i'm
asking for this is you know as a young
entrepreneur one of the things that i'm
always thinking about is you know how
you know how is the intersection of
technology and our physical world and so
i think that through some specific
examples i could get a lot of
inspiration as to okay what it can
actually be doing with technology in the
real world
okay so
let's start with the bees okay i in
the last three years i invested in two
companies that deal with it from
completely different angles
one is uh aruga aruga uh went into the
greenhouse and they said we wanna chase
we wanna
take the place of the bees the bees you
know don't always go out and pollinate
it's too hot too cold not enough light
they don't go out meaning you lose yield
because they didn't pollinate so they
said this is a huge problem we want to
solve this one first so they went into
you know the greenhouse built the robot
and the robot is doing a non-touch
pollination meaning if the bees for
example move from one plant to another
they can transfer
diseases
with the non-touch pollination this
cannot happen
so you say okay we are already in the
greenhouse we're doing pollination now
let's do
additional models what are the humans
doing so using robotics
to exchange a constraints in the
greenhouse making sure the yield is
stable
and
really you know at the level of the bees
or better than the beast
in that way you know you just let the
robot run in the greenhouse and it
happens you don't need to take care of
whether the bees
are healthy they are not healthy is
there a problem did they get out or not
did the hive die because of the heat
wave or not those things are out of the
equation at that place and the cost
is at because of the the improvement in
the
computing capability the eye
knowledge the cost is equivalent okay
a second solution is beehives you know
outside
outdoors beehives
almonds uh berries and so on
um
you put an iot b hero developed in an
internet of things a device that sits
inside the hive
and listen to the hives checks the
temperature or the movement if anything
goes wrong it flex the beekeeper
that something is going on go and get
there in the past the bee keepers you
know they would come
at a certain frequency if something goes
wrong it might be too late to recover
but if you get the alert immediately
online you can recover the hive very
fast and that increases the quality of
the highs and the quality of the
pollination
so those are two examples from a
completely different direction a
precision by the way i do have to say
with that last example um
you know the the ceo of b romer davidia
a good friend took me and along with a
few other folks in in california to an
area where they had beehives and they
showed us how how everything is working
and i have to say that from an
engineering you know perspective from
the back seat
it was one thing to see the ai models
and to understand the technology from
the luxury of my of my apartment in palo
alto being there physically with a
beekeeper and watching in the physical
world which is huge and vast in the hot
scorching sun
having to even imagine the beekeeper
doing what we did in one instance doing
it across
50 or 100 beehives in order to monitor
them on a daily basis
where now they can get a sensor and not
just optimize their time but know when
something is wrong you know as it's
happening and not not do it post-mortem
you know that to me being there in the
physical world that changed my
perspective that connection from you
know the laptop to actually being there
and seeing the elements grow and how the
beehives are impacting it so i think
that's really the the magic of what's
happening here with agritech right then
i think that you you got it right on the
spot this is mind-blowing technology
going into agriculture people don't
understand how far back agriculture is
from
the the technology we're used to
and the the fact that there are startups
that are introducing technology at the
highest level we're bringing high-tech
into agriculture
that's a huge change and an increase in
the efficiency and effectiveness of the
of the farmer
and it could be a beehive keeper and it
can be
a farmer or a grower or potatoes
uh right if you're talking about you
know
running
autonomous vehicles in the field
in the past it was mostly in open fields
now it's moving into orchards like blue
white robotics is developing and they
already deployed the technology
you can see uh precision irrigation
water constraint is becoming a huge
thing you know people cannot water as
much as they want
anymore the water price is going out the
water availability is going down
so two companies that i i'm invested
viridix is one and supplant is the
second one
um
to plant even taking it another step
forward and measuring
you know the the plant from additional
sensors not just soil sensor and that
way you can give the farmer
exact irrigation recommendation meaning
you don't over water which means you
waste water you don't underwater which
means you leave the plant
thirsty and
you optimize the yield and you see the
transition of higher yield because it's
optimized lower water consumption
and uh you know in dates for example
uh you can reduce about 50 of the water
consumption as the premium major
in the
southern areas of israel are getting the
higher premium percent so it's also the
quality of the food so this is now that
go ahead so now that we you know
understood a little bit about the the
physical landscape and what's happening
take me back 30 000 feet in the air
what's happening from you know an
investment body's perspective on you
know either israel as a tech powerhouse
for agritech or in terms of the world
how how are the investors responding to
this you know changing world and the
fact that now there's more entrepreneurs
going into agrotech
so first of all i would like to see more
entrepreneurs going into agritech i
think this is a really a
a call for action for inter
entrepreneurs yeah i see a lot of brain
power going into
gaming and
a nice consumer
solutions probably faster path to the
money
but the impact into the world is much
more lower
so i believe that uh
brainpower needs to move into agritech
more entrepreneurs need to move there in
israel there are about 400 companies
they're doing agritech
and some and you can see that the
industry is maturing there is more and
more startups
raising b rounds and the c rounds and
that's very impressive to see those
companies grow and improve their
capabilities and growing their sales
and um
from the other side i don't see enough
new startups stepping in
now one of the problems that
i think caused that is the fact that
there are not that many exits yet
in agritech
okay i think we're like a year
two years from the big exits it started
with prospero that did the three million
dollar sales i think there was another
company in the us to be the nexus for
something like 250 million dollars
it's starting the drops of the rain are
starting i believe that the
more rain of exits
is ahead of us this is why it's
attractive for
for vc's and for investors because we
are before
the this industry is going through the
major exits and
mergers and acquisitions and so
i think that uh
we are a bit behind the food industry
that is in a big height right right
right now right
um
and the nice thing about it the way i
see it as an investor is that the
company's pricing is more
aligned with the stage that the
companies are at
you know even some startup on food comes
with an idea about alternative protein
solution
they get money just for the idea
in architect you know you need some more
uh robust and materialized uh thing to
get funded
it happens but um
it's it's a bit more for me it's more
and you know being at the front being at
the
the first line of the investors in this
field i believe that this industry is
about to blow
incredible guinea take me back a little
bit to your
you know your your journey your
childhood what really
sparks your curiosity
you know growing up what really
fascinated you as a kid
first of all i read a lot as a kid and i
was extremely busy i i did sports i i
played professional basketball as a kid
and
i really enjoyed the connection between
you know school reading and uh
being very active socially in the school
and things like that
so um for me chemistry was fascinating
always was my passion
i recently learned that biology is more
interesting in my opinion
and um
when you look at the solutions coming
from the biology into this world like
crispr the ability to edit the genes a
biotechnology biological solutions into
a work chemistry existing in agriculture
culture
the fact that i you know by background
makes it very easy for me to understand
this
technology wise and scientific wise
helps me as an investor to be much much
smarter and more useful for the startup
so i think that passion that
to science and to
to uh technology that
goes with me all my life
is something that comes to play now in
uh the investment tool
i love it and and so i think that you've
touched on this quite a bit throughout
the conversation about you know where
you draw your own conviction and
inspiration today but what really
inspires you in your day-to-day of what
you do so you wake up every day
what really draws your inspiration
um
because of my very
different
experience that is not common in the
industry i was in corporate i know how
corporates think
and how they bring innovation in
i was in startups i know how hard it is
to raise money and to build their
relationship with your investors and i
am an investor i think this 360 degrees
look
on the startups arena is a strength i'm
trying to utilize this strength to
mentor startups
i'm
doing you know pro bono activity with
mass challenge with plug and play
whoever is interested in
getting my brain power
into play and you know pick my brand
under startups or ids
i'm making the time to do that so
positively impacting the ecosystem
helping entrepreneurs to bring their
ideas and make it a product and make it
a something sellable and really helping
know it's not a cliche we're trying to
save the world this is the money time so
wherever i can help people
you know put their finger and make a
difference
i'm i'm trying to help them
incredible and if there are a few words
that you would use to describe yourself
what would those be
um
people will say i'm
i'm on a turbo 24 7. so i'm
i'm busy i'm i like being busy and i
like doing multiple things in uh
i like mentoring i like discussion with
people that are open to listen
it's a two-way conversation
and these people are there i believe
that the entrepreneur that doesn't
listen
uh is in trouble
needs to listen to the market it's
listen to his board needs to listen to
his team
at the end they need to make the
decision but if you don't listen and
take everything into account you might
not make the best decision
um so
that's one thing
and i think that um
the passion the passion to do good
is something that when i wake up in the
morning you know today will end at the
8 p.m and then i will open my mails okay
i love it and i i i'm passionate about
it so it's not a problem
it's okay i enjoy it
this was amazing
thank you for fighting to
to make the world better literally
on one hand save it on the other hand
really make it better and not just with
your own work but the inspiration that
you bring either to the entrepreneurs
you're working with to your colleagues
um all the organizations that you
mentioned i'm honored to to work with
you also
as a part of the j ventures and i think
that um i i just want to continue
drawing on on your on your experience
and understandings
and
it leaves me optimistic so thank you
very much for the time and stay safe and
stay healthy thank you thank you bye
bye thank you